yes
you asked for it this is fun
[Music]
welcome to Universal CityWalk it's me
Mark and we're here on the street to
talk about Mario day and the upcoming
the Super Mario Brothers movie in
theaters soon there's a lot of fans
getting very pumped so we're going to
see what you're excited about what are
you nervous about what do you think this
movie could do on the Tomato Meter
are you pretty pumped for this thing oh
I'm pumped I'm ready to see it yes
absolutely hell yeah absolutely pumped I
cannot wait for it to come out pretty
excited it looks a lot better than the
90s movie
what about the movie gets you the most
exciting the impressive voice cast that
they have brought in and the animation
I'm really interested to see how they
take aspects of the games and put them
into the movie but I'm also just
interested in the plot I want some
Romance
okay you want some romance between
Princess Peach and Mario or do you want
something maybe she's hooking up with
the brother oh maybe there's a love
triangle with hopefully a love story
Mario and Peach but action and comedy I
was kind of shocked when I saw the
trailer I was like wait what I think the
trailer's surprising a lot of people
where you see oh this really looks like
they put a lot of love and care into it
was that the impression you got yeah
that's the impression I'm definitely
getting about it I'm excited to see it a
lot of people have made all kinds of
trailer analysis when they're pointing
out things in the background and things
from various games that they're like oh
this is from Galaxy and this is from 64.
I have been waiting for representation
of the Super Mario Brothers Super Show
since I was a kid even with this trailer
I am very satisfied just in the one
trailer where they show the toad land
there's so many themes in like one
minute you tell that people who loved
this worked on this movie well I did see
the smash reference between Donkey Kong
and Mario so like the Smash Brothers uh
reference was super cool yeah
ah you got the cat box oh my I'm sorry
okay now you die
here we go
hey hello is it me Mario Yahoo that was
adorable Yahoo
I mean I could probably do a good uh
Mario dime but that's about it
[Music]
do you have any good Super Mario
Brothers character Impressions you can
leave us with
no come on
come on Mushroom Kingdom
at Rotten Tomatoes we have this thing
called the Tomato Meter where it rates
how the critics feel about the film how
high do you think the Super Mario
Brothers movie is going to be on the
Tomato Meter do you think it's going to
be fresh or rotten I think it'll
probably be around 83 in the Rotten
Tomato score 100 crunch oh definitely
fresh I'm gonna be a little selfish here
I'm hoping for fresh I mean 64 could be
considered fresh right 64 is fresh and
it four would be cool I think it will be
the movie of all time there will be no
more movies after this it's over for
movies
there might be a sequel right maybe
regardless of what critics think
audiences are going to love this it's
not that it's a softball it's just you
can already tell that there's so much
love and craft into it critics are gonna
love it and audiences are gonna die for
it critics are critics right they're
gonna find something they always do I
don't know I'm worried I'm worried I'm
honestly worried he says he's worried
but he's got such a big smile on his
face I think it's tough because it's a
game that they're turning into a movie
but I I feel confident that they're
gonna get a frustrating I mean if this
could work with Pokemon detected Pikachu
the Sonic movies so can this a lot of
the video game movies recently have been
getting pretty good you know back then
they were kind of iffy and everyone was
like ah they kind of suck I think it's
in good hands I would say like a squishy
fresh but yeah still fresh
we may have just come up with a new
rating on Rotten Tomatoes for a movie
being between certified fresh and fresh
it's squishy fresh you heard it from
Kelsey and Nick first
[Music]
well so far everybody's getting into
Spirit here as we look forward to the
Super Mario Brothers movie folks seem to
think it's gonna be great how could it
not be with that cast Chris Pratt Anya
Taylor joy and think about all the funny
folks in this film Jack Black Sebastian
Maniscalco Keegan Michael Key Charlie
Day this movie should have something for
people of all ages I'm even getting into
the spirit a little bit so now let's go
ask folks about celebrating Mario Day
how do you celebrate Mario Day in your
household we're probably going to play
some of our favorites uh personally big
big Mario Kart girls it's actually a
tradition in my friend group we're all
Nintendo fans so we go to my friend's
basement and we just play Smash all day
all right I'm gonna go to Ralph's
dressed up as Luigi in grocery shop I'm
just gonna play games all day I'm Gonna
Keep It Easy play Super Mario Brothers 3
and just beat it in one go you could
beat it in one in one life
no a theme dinner sounds nice that would
be fun maybe some candles or something
yeah
probably something with mushrooms right
there's some sort of mushroom risotto
not those kind of mushrooms their dirty
minds took that to a different place
Portobello that's just portobello
mushrooms is all we need
um
at work I'm probably just gonna change
my slack Emoji to one for Mario Mario
day should be an international day that
you get off work though I think we can
all agree to that happy Mario day happy
Mario Day
anticipation for the Super Mario
Brothers movie so many great fans here
on the street at Universal CityWalk now
it's your turn comment let us know what
are you excited about with the new flick
how did you celebrate Mario day and do
you have any Impressions that can rival
what you saw in this fit it's a lot of
talented folks walking around CityWalk
thanks so much for tuning in to this
episode of on the street with Rotten
Tomatoes like subscribe and we'll see
you next time
supposed to have something else right
what was it uh we're talking about
Donuts all right are you guys good sorry
you got kicked out of the Kelly Clarkson
show